okay game going vs baltimora from the UK
go for the king's indian again we got
some Petrossian variation in fact them
this line that he is played on isn't
that great because of what's happening
right now what did that make some
mistake here this looks strange actually
the line isn't that great but not sure
if it is for this reason or something
else this actually looks fine for white
not sure yeah of course
yeah it's very classical position here
with the inferior bishop on g7 but black
has got chances to to activate this
piece on age 60 it's a much less of a
problem than in no similar positions
check
yeah I need to trade off some pieces hmm
yeah not sure it's this really good for
white play a five now what then the new
world would take but then I get on the
second-ranked i can't i can't play a
five he shouldn't shouldn't be a problem
Oh class I've heard he's simply closing
up everything ok and then offering a
draw yeah of course it's difficult to
make any progress here hmm
hmm
I'll play a couple of moves but this is
really just a draw is certainly correct
in this
grah offered game glass yeah that was of
course very dull play with p5 yeah yeah
not much she can do